We've surpassed a pretty important number.
More than half of the country now believes
that Donald [inaudible]
should not only be impeached by the house
of representatives, but also removed by a
Senate conviction.
Now, I still don't think it's going to happen,
but if anything will make it even a remote
possibility.
As I've said before, it's, if even Republican
opinion turns in that direction, Oh, I don't
believe it'll happen because 62% of Trump
has said, there is no way ever that they will
abandon Donald Trump.
But let's take it one step at a time.
Uh, we have a new ABC Ipsos poll, in which
51% 51% of Americans believe that Donald Trump
should be removed from office via impeachment.
This is more than half the country.
70% believe that Donald Trump was wrong to
pressure the Ukrainian president to launch
smear investigations into Joe and Hunter Biden.
Now, you might see these numbers and think,
well, if 51% of the country wants Trump removed,
certainly he will lose reelection in 2020.
Right?
We'll know because remember, many Americans
don't vote 51% 60% even 65% of the country
might want Donald Trump removed, but half
the country doesn't vote, and if it's more
of the people on our side than the people
on Trump's side that choose to stay home in
November of 2020 he can still easily get reelected,
particularly because of the electoral college
system.
However, our relevant comparison is that these
numbers are more aggressively against Trump
than how public opinions saw Richard Nixon
at this early stage of the impeachment inquiry
during the 1970s that doesn't bode super well
for Donald Trump.
Now, in the don't impeach Trump side, there
are a few shades of opinion.
There are sort of some, uh, there's some fracturing
going on that's important to think about.
You've got conservative Republicans who don't
think Trump is a good president.
They may even think what Donald Trump has
done is wrong with Ukraine, emoluments, Yemen,
whatever, but they just don't think it rises
to the level of warranting impeachment.
Okay.
That's one sort of group that's kind of like
maybe the national review possession position.
In fact, a rich Lowery might even have written
something like this in the national review
and gotten into my brain somehow, and I don't
remember the specifics, but this is what I
would guess is sort of like a national review
rich Lowery position on impeachment.
Then you've got the sort of mildly ignorant
Republicans who aren't necessarily big Trump
Brown nosers, but they rest easy on talking
points, like all politicians do bad things
or I'm not really affected by this personally,
so I don't care.
Or the stock market's doing well or whatever
that they don't really have to think about,
wow, maybe I should be thinking about voting
for a Democrat in November of 2020 that's
another, that's like an in between sort of
crowd.
And then you have like the real pro Trump
sycophants who can see Trump do no wrong and
will defend him no matter what he does.
According to a recent poll, that's 62% of
Donald Trump supporters who are in the, even
hypothetically, I can't think of anything
Trump could do that would make me question
my support for him.
So step one is Trump has to be removed, however,
voted out impeachment.
As unlikely as that would be.
Step two is that a lot of those people who
right now have these milk toast views on Trump,
the right wingers who don't like him, but
they don't really see him as a big problem.
We're going to have to deal with that, and
this is why I've been talking for months now,
if not longer about the damage done by Trump
will outlast his presidency because when Donald
Trump is removed or goes away, you know whatever
goes away ends.
His second term is removed after one term
is impeached, whatever the case may be.
We are going to see some people take the position
of, well, Trump has gone so the Republican
party is fixed.
Everything's back to normal.
The country's back to normal.
Aside from the policy issues and the alliances
that have been destroyed and our reputation,
which has been a laughingstock for a couple
of years, you have to remember that the Republican
party is responsible for the circumstances.
That got us to a point where Donald Trump
was able to win a Republican primary and then
a national election in 2016 and they have
been unwilling to deal with him and that throughout
his presidency.
So it will be really important that whenever
Donald Trump ultimately leaves office, it
has to be made clear that the Republican party
is still as much of a problem as it was in
the lead up to Donald Trump becoming president
and throughout his presidency.
This may be a conversation that is not relevant
until January of 2025 if Donald Trump wins
reelection, it may be relevant much sooner
if Donald Trump loses reelection or even in
the unlikeliest of scenario, a scenarios is
removed via impeachment sooner than that,
much like Republicans normalized George W.
Bush and now have actually even helped to
rehabilitate his image.
Although Donald Trump has certainly played
a role in rehabilitating W's image as well,
the same sort of indifferent Republicans who
don't love Trump, but they don't see him as
a systemic menace.
They may be able to rehabilitate own image
if it's not made clear that Trump is the outcome
of how they allowed the Republican party to
change over the last many years.
Uh, it is not merely a blip on the radar.
It is the conclusion.
It was the end to the means, so to speak.
That was the radicalization, uh, D intellectual
ization.
I know that's not the, the, the right word
or maybe even a word, but I think you know
what I mean.
Uh, and cartoon suffocation of the Republican
party over the last many years, and particularly
much of that was catalyzed and aggravated
by their deep hate of Barack Obama, some of
which was racially motivated.
Uh, and some of it, some, some of which was
not a, but we will talk about that when the
time comes in.
The time may be soon.
The time may be in January of 2021.
It may not be until January, 2025.
Hopefully that's not the case.